space is taking the first step even when
you don't see the whole staircase Martin
Luther King jr. on august twenty-third
1963 a quarter of a million people went
to Washington DC Sakir martin luther
king jr. speak at the Lincoln Memorial
how did he get so many people to come
out he didn't have a newsletter or a
Twitter account he wasn't making YouTube
videos or using google adwords he didn't
have a website or use Facebook he didn't
have any of the tools that make it so
easy for us today to reach people and
start movement and yet 250,000 people
came out why because he stood for
something important the cars he believed
in touch people's hearts and led them to
action it was so important that people
willingly spread the word and promoted
his cause because it was there cause you
need to do the same what does it have to
do with business you must be thinking
that's great it works in political or
cultural movement but what does this
have to do with business I'm glad you
are what we're talking about here is
getting people to take action
influencing decision making by appealing
to something that people feel passionate
about it can apply to go into your
website and find your products just as
easily as it does to getting in the bus
and traveling to hear Martin Luther King
jr. see most companies just never do it
your business is not just about making a
product or service that's a recipe for
failure people want to know who you are
and what you stand for before they'll
buy anything from you it's about
standing for something important and
having your cause be your customers
cause